[Music]
have you guys put any thought into how
different the world's gonna be after
this whole crisis and one restaurants
reopen like what's gonna be the
processor I can't even fathom it I'm
just thinking about like the economy
like so number one the unemployment I
think it's at like 50 percent or
something now 20 million jobs yes
there's all these jobs that are gone and
then you and pretty soon if we keep
staying in a lot of the businesses are
gonna go down you know you have a huge
population of people I need job but then
there's not that many businesses to hire
jobs so I don't know usually it's
supposed to going like this right it's
like a little psycho theme but then just
multiple pieces that are broken so I
don't know everything
sorry if you hear meowing it's because
we have a stray kitten here moving on
I'm listening this one restaurant open
up and then they started having people
in their own little pods see that like
there's this one restaurant that opened
up I think it was in another country and
they started putting people in like
glass pods so you have your own I want
to see that in China
Oh 24-hour Fitness is opening up yeah in
the beer no have you seen have you seen
that video here there's notes in the
bank they just released a video and
24-hour Fitness la yeah so they sent me
the email like hey come in soon and the
way they're doing it now is that there's
groups of no they set up so the only
groups of people can come in for an hour
at a time and you to reserve it on the
app so like ten people come in and then
it goes down for half an hour whether
you watch that's what we're gonna have
to do it had to be per hour oh so we're
gonna use a time slot we're gonna yeah
we're gonna have people reserve their
time that they want to come in we can
only have a certain mountain people and
then we have to close it down for like
an hour to so that we can disinfect
everything and then open back up hold
I like how creative everyone's being
with it it's very cool solutions one
image with the with the with in a gym
where they put the glass like partitions
they put it in between each was it like
cross treadmill treadmill yeah that was
a 24 in the hood so they don't shoot
each other cuz I used to like blasting
each other good
I was like a lot of people hopefully
they stick to it but a lot of wood I've
been afraid to like work out they're
like oh this is kind of my own privacy
and also for the guys that creep on
curls or like I can now actually run a
piece and not some guy just sit next to
me try to talk to ya that's I was about
to mention that too because I was
looking at some comments of people what
they were saying and everyone's like
this will actually make me want to go to
the job cuz I'm like yeah it's just
annoying watch other kitties on your
feet
yeah 24-hour fitness they are one thing
that was interesting is it you know how
they had classes in there like a lot of
dance room yeah so I guess they wanted
it to be more spread out you need all
the the whatever the button the spin
bikes nice yeah they moved into the
basketball court so everyone's super
spread out even know basketball yeah
well like there's so many people that
sign up for 24 just to play basketball
indoors but you might even gonna play
back there's there's contact maybe no
contact how do you eliminate did it by
putting bikes in the way you can't yeah
how do you play you need contact and
basketball that's how you play defense
but it's like there's other things
because from my thing is like okay so
you use the bench right and then they
clean it once an hour but how many
people use it per hour I think the only
the one person you only I'm not allowed
to use it what's public transit gonna be
like like the buses and the subways
because that's where a lot of diseases
are in other places I still have it like
New York during this whole thing they
still cuz that's how its spread so crazy
over there yeah but even now like they
still use it like almost the same I
wonder if they have to like they block
off the seats so you can have to sit
further away and do they Santa do they
sanitize like every hour like no they
did they just did like a full deep clean
yeah for the first time like a hundred
years well he said yeah when I read that
it's a misleading headline yeah cuz
their judgement like yeah they're saying
that those the first time that they
completely shut down service you clean
everything at once well then people took
that as this is the first time you're
cleaning the trains in a hundred years
funnier that way it looks like yeah I'm
clean it okay so the story I have here
is this restaurant the Swedish
restaurant called board for in that
translates to table for one and so
they're saying that once they're able to
open back up and accept people in their
new restaurants this is what the
restaurant is it's just one table from
outdoors in the middle of a field and
you receive your food in this basket it
comes in on this line that's connected
to a kitchen it doesn't look safe for a
windy day for a rainy day
yeah no weed yeah and it snows a lot of
horse mates
no but you like that restaurant
experience yeah but you like it you go
all the time I'll just buy yourself to
eat alone I eat alone a lot out of empty
restaurant I live with my girlfriend so
usually it's not empty but I would
prefer it empty I'm not single yeah you
know I like eating you know what I like
to eat alone Japan because you don't
feel alone but they make it where man I
don't know they they make it where you
feel like yeah you're not interrupted
huh where they hit pretty hard yeah
there's some places that like they tried
to open back up and then there's a spike
again right now cuz also they probably
kill in cleanliness and also like isn't
like the ramen spots pretty much exactly
how little like for yourself and then
it's like certain time amount of time
that you have to sit and like you have
to leave after that yeah my mom's out
there my stepdads like at risk because
of the like health and age and all that
but they get a grocery delivered they
get like a lot of these things pretty
done they just don't go out to eat
anymore we go that's the thing that I'm
like really curious about like how is
the restaurant experience good night I
heard buffets are gonna suffer for sure
yeah I saw this one video where um this
lady she comes out and then there's like
a line so like there's a table like okay
this is a table right and then like this
is the door where she came out and so
she's coming out of the restaurant and
there's like a line right here so she's
standing behind the line which is a six
feet apart and then so she has think
drink so she just throws that up the
empty the empty table like pretending to
serve and they're saying like this is
help things are gonna be served now like
the waitstaff we're just gonna throw
your [ __ ] cuz it has to have that
distance it was pretty funny but and you
just hear like all the globey yeah so I
there's this other restaurant in
Washington I do miss restaurant food
because even though like all the food
delivery is awesome when it comes it's
like half as good as it was at the
restaurant cold yeah it's not this
it's like it has to be there yeah like
the point especially Mexican food man
it's like it's a ticking time bomb
yeah the rice has to be a certain
temperature the fish has to be a certain
temperature yeah true okay so there's
this other restaurant it's called the
Inn at little Washington but it's in
Virginia and it's a three Michelin star
restaurant and they're planning on
opening they're planning on opening for
dinner on May 29th and there are saying
and because they can only have half
capacity like outdoor seating they and
like for the indoor seating go there
they didn't want to make it so awkward
so what they're doing is they're
dressing mannequins and like 19th that's
very you don't feel like alone it's like
the weird like empty or empty rest it's
like last night on earth so much worse
Oh cut it out that's like some
apocalypse like zombie [ __ ] like I ain't
got no friends that's I am Legend right
there because what if they do at least
like modern clothes were the like skinny
jeans with tie-dye shirts or something
looking like some Victorian ghost is
eating next to you I'm cool man if I was
on acid I would have been [ __ ] going
crazy
you'd be funnier though that I would
like if you had cardboard cutouts of the
people it's all flat yeah but didn't a
haven't seen any same places I would
like that they should just have like
like one of the zoom meetings and they
deliver the food there where you feel
like you're still in a restaurant yeah
they deliver it at home huh delivery the
food and you have a camera in front of
you and then you can see the rest you
look at the restaurant or just all we
are who's gonna be the delivery food not
the yummy food or they deliver you the
ingredients I don't mind an empty
restaurant I get it and eve's just try
not to leave this house I want to go to
the restaurant for the environment I
wonder how much if they can afford yeah
one customer every hour and it's like
the whole staff and it's like what the
[ __ ] can you afford all that I don't
know well in this particular restaurant
they say that it has 23 guest rooms and
they plan to capitalize on its twenty
acre property by offering picnic lunch
and garden tours
businesses are still gonna go out of
business it's just how are you gonna
sustain your cost of operation if you
just don't have that amount of clients
unless people are willing to pay like
premium like a huge customer pays like a
thousand bucks yeah whoa that's quite
the experience that no one's gonna no
one has that money cuz no one hasn't the
job yeah well if they get their $1200
they could use to go thousand classifies
it like as an official recession like
you know in 2008 like that was an
official like recession like are we in
in a kind of yeah we are kind of a
narrow recession right and then what's
the difference between a recession and
depression how badly the economy Thanks
and if your pictures are in black and
white or not that's true I think the the
reason why they're not calling a
recession or depression yet because
they're hoping it's not gonna be long
term yeah they're hoping it's gonna
spike up quickly after like economy I
think some people they have so there's
different metrics I think some people
they base it off like the interest rate
so if they're dropping it down and it's
because they have to I mean we're in
like those are the signs of the
recession but then once it starts coming
back up cuz everyone has money and it's
like the loans aren't that easy to get
there's like all these different
national interest rates I know is one of
them and there's like two or three that
baby gauge and all three of them I hit
then you're officially in a recession
that's the case yeah I'm sure what the
restaurants are gonna have like some
with especially with the whole country
has to get some type of aid hopefully
but like this little business is better
than no business they're probably
they're gonna cut staff like that's one
thing that they're gonna have to do they
can't know if they want to keep their
loan without having to pay it back well
in the games alone you know well the
staff doesn't want to work if they're
getting unimpeded
so what the thing with that is though if
if they're able to work they have to go
back to work and they have to stop
getting the thing I don't know how you
have to track them down but the less the
only reason they can and they can stay
on unemployment is if your job site is
not safe and they didn't make it safe
enough for the whole virus thing but
that's the tricky part of people it's
not safe I'm not going back and I keep
calling these fat ass checks yeah but
then I saw like this one tweet where
Trump is like I don't go [ __ ] take the
money away from people that don't want
to go back to work so yeah I just want
sushi
you know what up there's got to be some
desperate chefs out there that are like
man I haven't made some sushi in a
minute sure I'd go to your house and buy
me to your house I'm a punk a the other
they hire this one dude and we'll just
chill in one table and he could live his
dreams you know what we could do we do
that
but like say you have a party you just
hire like a chef that you know they
could be like oh cool service social but
you know I think with like people's
gonna now there's test kits that you can
know immediately so you could just have
test kits and a lot of people do this I
mean like you know how like Joe Rogan
was testing every person that comes in
you get immediate results yeah actually
now it's it's easy to where you get a
finger prick and then you test thank god
is that [ __ ] nose thing yeah you
don't have to send it to a lab that's
how they test you say I feel like you're
touching and touching her brain yeah so
imagine if we test the sushi chef oh but
if you fix his finger I don't want that
blood on the sushi so damn it and a dude
bending maybe with his tongue like part
of the keel like baby's like a prick his
penis free-cos penis yeah yeah yeah but
I think you first had to get it hard
yeah I don't think you could pick us off
penis you got to get it hard so Bart
will get Bart to make it hard what if
too much comes out then sort of blood
like a flow fountain gorged with blood
Hey Joe this this blood is white like I
don't know man
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]